let's go with a simplified version of
the whole thing we're going to talk
about simplifying the only applause well
there's going to be the ambient brdf how
does it look like well first first on
the left side I see I this is intensity
well what is this well no one knows
because we have not radiance not
something very physical here this is
going to be a simplified version of the
whole rendering equation basically a
bunch of hex if you look something that
is vastly simplified it doesn't really
have a physical meaning it doesn't have
physical units but it works it's
beautiful and it's a good way to
understand what's going on so the
intensity that we measure is going to be
it an ambient the product of an ambient
coefficient of an object this is
dependent of the object this means that
this means something like the color of
the object and the eye is going to be
the intensity the ambient intensity of
the scene for the light source and later
on you're going to be talking about why
this is interesting so this is an
example we have a blue object over here
and it's the same color everywhere why
because the formula doesn't depend on
anything there's just one for efficient
that's multiplied by this intensity of
the scene so that's an ambient shading
what else is there there's the diffuse
brdf this is what we compute is a
diffuse coefficient what is the diffuse
color diffuse albedo of this thing and
there's going to be a product of L into
M this is what we did before diffuse
objects look like that please raise your
hand if you have ever done any kind of
diffused loved version model in graphics
okay excellent great and just another
thing this deviance coefficient is the
very least RGB okay so this is how much
light is another
observed on every different wavelength
because I cannot describe colors in one
number the very least RGB or a
continuous spectrum just for the record
and now it's looking better because I
can more or less see where the light
source is with for this diffuse shading
there's also a specular brdf what I
compute is V dot R times
specular coefficient and V is the vector
pointing towards the viewer and Oren's
to reflect it there's going to be
examples of that and so just that you've
seen the formula and there's an M which
is a shininess factor in the next
assignment you will play with this
yourself so for now I will keep this a
secret what this exactly does and whoops
I'm gonna jump through this because I
would like to ask a question later on
and you're going to find out the
solution excuse me so this is how the
specular highlights look and if I add up
all of these things ambient and diffuse
and specular I get some complex looking
model that looks something that is that
approximates a physical reality so I
just simply add all these terms up ok
well I have something like this here and
I have on purpose removed the light
source from this image but probably
everyone can help where the light source
is expected to be right so raise your
hand if you know where the light source
should be okay cool where should it be
exactly well exactly so it's kind of a
above spheres and this is exactly where
it is so these material models are
descriptive
way that that I get images that have
some physical meaning that resemble
physical reality well let's let's take a
look at an actual example the question
is what would this region look like the
one that I marked like this pixel if
pixels existed in the real world would
it look the same if I move my head in
reality and that son that sounds I can
you know this it sounds like a tricky
question yet I have seen the answer is
well let's say that this part is purely
diffuse I don't see many specular
reflections in there the fuse is l dot M
so light vector Direction times to
normal
does it change if I move my head well
how to answer this question you don't
want me to see what is in an equation
you are of you you have to be aware of
what is not in there does it change if I
move my head raise your hand if you know
the answer it's very apparent to many of
you yes true answer yes it does not
change if I move will do okay but then I
change because the specularity might
move was it yes that's that's very true
so it doesn't change because we know
that it doesn't change I mean the walls
look the same if I mean if I move around
I mean talking about shapes or talking
about colors they don't change the
mirror however does that change and the
mathematical reason for this is that the
view direction is not in this equation I
can change the view direction all I want
and nothing will change in the diffusely
idea so this is like a general
mathematical trick or principles that
you can use in a number of different
things don't just don't just look at
what variables
in there try to think of variables what
you would imagine that would be there
and okay why are they missing and that's
that's also information that's what
they're and not only ones there but what
is missing is valuable information so
what about these regions these are
specular highlights these are described
by the specular be or dfv dove also
viewing Direction times the reflected
light direction and let's actually
compute what's going on so I will be
interested in the intensity this fake
something of this point where this is
the light vector this is where it points
to it is probably reflected somewhere
there because it comes in and it's any
deep ideal reflection so it's going to
be reflected in this direction and this
is where I am just for example so I'm
interested in vor well this is going to
be a cosine there is a small angle
between V and R so if there's a small
angle that's cosine of a small number
that's large
that's goes to one and there's going to
be a huge scalar product therefore this
point is bright and this is indeed
bright and the question is which is very
easy to insert in a second is doesn't
change if I move around doesn't change
obviously it does change because V is in
the equation and if I change this around
is exactly different for the specular
brdf this is going to be bright just one
of my favorite intuitions of this V
Dugger because otherwise this is just
letters this means how much am i
standing in the way of the light so life
lesson if you can't find the water
droplets on the floor after having a
shower move your head around because
that's specular if the windshield of a
car is too bright and it
and you just can't take it anymore move
your head around this is connected to
the physical reality around us and
that's good tips in case you didn't know
that you need to move your head around
basically right now you know okay so
this is the point where we can just for
a second stop and marvel at how
beautiful things we can create with such
simple equations and the rendering
equation is going to be even more to
default on that line infinitely was
before and there is some additional
beauty that you can think about when you
look at images like that okay how would
I shape this point it's this diffuse if
is this specular why does it look the
way it does so you can if you have
nothing better to do you can think about
these things when on public transport
let's call this st. the illumination
equation this is the simpler version of
the rendering equation now what is it
that most of this is familiar there is
an ambient shading term and then there
is the diffuse l dot n there is the
specular read of our we add all these
together and we multiply this by the
amount of incoming light because if
there's no light sources in the scene
there is no life light is not coming
from anywhere
this is 1/0 if there's a bright light
source that things get brighter so we
multiply by this incoming light and what
is important to know is that this is
only direct effect of light sources this
sounds a bit esoteric at the moment but
later on a few lectures down the road
we're going to be all about indirect
illumination and goodies like that and
this is neglected and the ambient term
is used to make up for it you will see
examples of this in the next lecture and
this is a crude approximation but it's
still beautiful it's easy to understand
and it serves as a stepping stone to
solve the real rendering equation but
this is not done one thing is that if
there are multiple light sources the
scene is expecting to be brighter so I
would compute the whole thing for
multiple light sources so there's going
to be a sum in there and then inside the
Sun this the indexes are the number of
light sources basically just I just
didn't want to over complicate this but
still something is still missing
this is this is not done I arrived to a
point I compute this specular ambient
and if you shading and I am not done
let's discuss how ray tracing works and
people find out so the first thing is
that what you see here is non-trivial
because what you would imagine is that
you start shooting rays from the light
source and then some of the rays would
make up to make it to the camera to your
eye and and most of them won't so we go
with a simple optimization that we turn
the whole thing around and then we start
tracing rays from the camera because if
I start tracing from there I can
guarantee that
I deal with race
not wasted because they look I'm not
interested in the light rays that do not
make it to the camera so if I start from
there I can guarantee that this is not
wasted computation so how do we do this
there is this camera plane we will
discuss how to construct such a thing
and we construct rays through this
camera plane and what I am interested in
is the projection of the 3d world to
display this is what you will see on
your monitor so I should raise from this
camera and I intersect this against
objects that are in the scene I want to
know where is the light stopping where
what objects does it hit and where does
it get reflected so the second is
intersection with scene objects I have
to realize that it hits this sphere then
I stop there I compute the basic shading
terms like the diffuse and the rest and
then I don't stop there but I'm
interested in where the light is
reflected I need to continue from here
and this life this light rate may be
reflected or refracted and I need some
kind of recursion in order to account
from that for that and the recursion
works in the following way
I stop at this point where I hit the
ball the sphere and what I do is that I
imagine that this is now the starting
point of the rain and I'm shooting the
ray outwards and I start this ray
tracing algorithm again so this is how
the recursion works this was missing
from the formula and this is just what
the text version of what
set for those who are reading this at
home and you will deal with refractions
yourself